depuis deux jours minneapolis est le
théâtre de scènes violentes entre forces
de l'ordre et manifestants
les mouvements de protestation contre le
meurtre de george floyd et 46 cents par
des policiers se multiplient
le maire et le gouverneur du minnesota
tente de calmer la situation
s'il vous plaît minneapolis nous ne
pouvons pas laisser la tragédie a
engendré plus de tragédies la zone le
long du lac est devenue dangereuse
nous demandons votre aide pour maintenir
la paix ce soir la situation près de
l'extrémité y à watts à minneapolis est
devenue une situation extrêmement
dangereuse pour la sécurité de tous
veuillez quitter la zone et autoriser
les pompiers et les ambulanciers
paramédicaux à se rendre sur les lieux
c'est donc une vidéo de l'arrestation
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux qui met
le feu aux poudres en début de semaine
on y voit john floyd agonisant sur le
sol sous le genou d'un policier et
supplier pour qu'on lui laisse la vie
sauve
la colère voilà donc le sentiment qui
règne aujourd'hui dans les rues de
minneapolis c'est le pire passage à
tabac de la police de tous les temps et
je dis toujours que je ne peux rien voir
de pire que les coûts de rodney king
c'est pire que rodney king dans le
contexte de cet homme souffrant pendant
9 minutes
nous devons nous rassembler rester unis
ce n'est pas normal nous sommes en 2020
le virus ne tue la police nous tue le
gouvernement n'aide personne
pour l'avocat de la famille de josh
floyd rien ne peut justifier un tel
comportement
si vous avez un téléphone portable à
vous le prenez vous réglez votre
chronomètre sur neuf minutes vous vous
asseyez vous laisser le temps passé et à
ce moment là vous imaginez quelqu'un
avec son genou contre votre coup alors
que vous vous débattez pour pouvoir
respirer alors que personne ne fait rien
pour que vous puissiez respirer et bien
tout ça ce sont les dernières minutes de
la vie de georges floyd en un mot c'est
un meurtre il n'y a rien qui justifie
cela en ce qui concerne le gouvernement
justement à donald trump lui aussi a
réagi
le président américain demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête à ma demande
le fbi et le ministère de la justice ont
déjà entamé une enquête sur la mort très
tristes et tragiques de djorf floyd au
minnesota
c'est donc une affaire qui en rappellent
d'autres aux états unis depuis plusieurs
années les victimes noires sous les
coups de policier blanc se multiplient
aujourd'hui les quatre policiers
responsables de la mort de georges floyd
ont été renvoyés les autorités locales à
vous aujourd'hui vouloir mettre tout en
oeuvre pour faire la lumière sur cette
terrible tragédie